yama trauma is a local delicacy of meats
literally every kenyan is familiar with
yama coma messiah style of cooking has
found itself into Cajun cuisine some
people are still keeping it very simple
where others have gotten more treated
and added more spices and marinades to
cooking their me hi my name is Fred
Mejia I'm the general manager of
Carnival restaurant Nairobi Kenya
carnival as the main suggests is that
animal that preys on hobby balls so we
are a restaurant ourselves all kinds of
meats it's popularly known as Neama
Chama
which is Swahili for barbecue literally
every Kenyan is a familiar with Yama
Yama or barbecue meat it's what most
people would eat especially on weekends
Yama Chama the carnival is slightly
different from what people do at home or
fun events because we comprise of a huge
variety from the domestic meat such as
beef lamb chicken talked to exotics like
ostrich crocodile and occasionally camel
meat our style of barbecue is rather
unique we use Messiah Spears and swad we
modify this to be able to hold a meat of
a hot coals while it's being barbecued
right here the carnival on the back of
the premises we have a kiln where we
make charcoal we mainly use the acacia
tree we give seedlings to the Masai
communities they grow the trees we buy
them back from them and when they're
mature we cut them down put them in the
kiln and we make choco this choco
becomes the main fuel for barbecuing the
meats it imparts a special smoky flavor
and make the meats really delicious
we make our marinades the whole idea is
just to salt the meat a little bit
without adding too many things that
changes
natural flavors of the meat so marinades
comprised of oil vinegar fresh herbs
standing on the type of meat that we are
going to marinate in that right next on
these premises we have a small kitchen
garden where we grow our own hubs and we
use all these in our kitchens the
carnival restaurant opened in 1980 we
serve it in a special way because we
bring it to the middle of the table with
a wide variety of sauces and side dishes
the covers carve the meat on hot plates
hot cast-iron plates and the meat is
cured on Messiah Spears and swords which
makes it very unique and great eating
all our meats are sourced locally meats
like chicken beef and lamb is all found
by local farmers in Kenya it is illegal
to hunt a wild game the only game that
one can be able to serve is what is
farmed in ranches one of them are farms
ostrich it's unique in flavor it's still
very gamey and it's a very popular in
our restaurant the other exotic meat is
a crocodile crocodile is farmed mainly
for its a skin you can get this in many
places around the world Yama Yama is a
part of Kenya's cuisine from way back
most of the communities in Kenya used to
do a lot of hunting and they used to
make their own homemade meals from meat
particularly the Maasai community in
Kenya whose diet is predominantly meat
so this caught on and has become a
popular delicacy in literally all parts
of Kenya and the carnival we've
introduced this as part of our menu to
visitors from fine abroad to try
something which is part of our culture
hi I'm Kalamazoo a producer for tasty
and this is my family's ranch located in
the mountains of Sultan Hamid Kenya on
the ranch we raise cows goat and sheep
today we're going to be preparing
samosas I'll barbecue for my uncle's
wedding we're expecting about a thousand
guests so we're gonna prepare two cows
seven goats and three sheep this style
of preparing and barbecuing meat is the
traditional Masai way of cooking
everything that is used to cook is found
here on the land the wood we use comes
from the acacia tree which grows
naturally in this environment we raise
the same animals that we end up eating a
lot of people are involved in wrangling
these animals because they can be quite
dangerous so you'll have a lot of people
either in the home or neighbors come
very early in the morning to help with
the butchering process for everyone's
safety the cuts of meat differ than the
Western cuts at a butcher would know
these cuts are decided by the elders and
not only about which pieces get cut but
also who gets to eat which pieces
there's certain pieces of meat that I
reserve for a special guests elder men
pieces for elder women as well as pieces
that the men barbecuing get to eat
before everyone else in the party gets
served the meat is skewered on a plant
very similar to eucalyptus and that
provides flavors in meat while being
roasted the meat is not cooked over
direct flames but rather the charcoal
that's made from the acacia tree the
flavoring of the meat purely comes from
the smoke the wood is cooked on and a
little bit of salt after the meat is
done the side people really enjoy the
natural flavor of the meat the tradition
of roasting meat is done by the moran's
of our tribe who are the Warriors of the
Maasai tribe
however because of Education you have a
lot of younger Masai people who aren't
spending as much time home and have
learn these traditions so it's actually
the elders in the tribe who are now
dictating how the entire barbecuing
should be done around the barbecue
there's a big pot of soup and inside of
the pot is just water and bones
medicinal plants and tree barks would be
added to soup and Lister's as detox
cleansing soup that is generally
consumed after having a very heavy meal
Masaya style of cooking has found itself
into Cajun cuisine you'll see Yama Choma
which means barbecued meat in almost any
kind of restaurant and the meat itself
has taken up its own form where some
people are still keeping it very simple
and only adding salt where others have
gotten more creative and added more
spices and marinades today meat meat is
a big part of Masai cuisine if not a
majority of it once a week we will take
an animal from the farm and that will
provide food for the entire week for the
household this style of raising your own
food and then using everything is a big
part of our culture and a center point
for a lot of our traditions Maasai were
a nomadic tribe our history is passed on
through oral tradition this is unique to
us
for the last 38 years we migrated to
Kenya and Tanzania centuries ago along
the way we herded the animals so it's
not a normal fear that you get in any
other restaurant in Kenya this practice
of cooking eating has been with their
tribe since before we even arrived in
Kenya
bye-bye I made a pun you never do that